sarrazin endgültig aus der partei
geworfen das steht seit heute fest das
oberste parteischiedsgericht bestätigt
den parteiausschluss des umstrittenen
autors am freitagmittag die entscheidung
begründet es damit dass zum schutz des
ansehens und der glaubwürdigkeit der spd
das vorgehen rechtmäßig sei sarrazin
habe erheblich gegen die grundsätze und
die ordnung der partei verstoßen und ihr
damit schaden zugefügt generalsekretär
lars klingbeil erklärt auf twitter thilo
sarrazin ist nicht mehr mitglied der spd
drei anläufe hatte die spd seit 2010
gestartet jetzt ist thilo sarrazin also
tatsächlich raus genau darüber möchte
ich sprechen mit bild reporter aus der
politik ralf schuler der jetzt bei mir
es reift du hast mit thilo sarrazin
jetzt kontakter wie genau reagiert er
auf seinen ausschluss
ich glaube er hat ein stück weit damit
gerechnet er ist sehr gelassen und ruhig
er hatte schon bei den vorherigen
verhandlungen angekündigt dass er den
gesamten rechtsweg notfalls ausschreiten
will und notfalls bis vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen will
und insofern ist jetzt die
mitgliedschaft erst einmal erloschen
erwartet jetzt auf das urteil auf die
schriftliche begründung die muss
innerhalb von drei wochen kommen und
wird dann den nächsten klageweg einlegen
im augenblick flüchtig dass ich so ein
bisschen in gelassenheit und sagte ja
gut dann spart da immer in den
mitgliedsbeitrag seine frau ist auch
gleich noch ausgetreten aber es geht
natürlich tiefer und es geht eigentlich
im kern auch um seine ehre wenn man so
will hat in der verhandlung immer wieder
darauf bestanden dass man ihm zitate des
inkriminierten buches die feindliche
übernahme wie der islam die gesellschaft
gefährdet vorlegen soll die entweder
kultur rassistisch wie die vorwürfe
lauteten oder aber irgendwie
fremdenfeindlich oder schädlich seien
oder falsch und er hat dann hinterher
auch gesagt ja man hat mir nichts
nachweisen können haben wir nichts
zeigen können es ist nichts was man mir
vorwerfen kann und dementsprechend sah
es ist etwas verstörend dass eine
falsche meinung dazu führen kann dass
man aus der partei geworfen wird
das sagt er
jetzt ist das ganze thema also noch
nicht vorbei weil er den rechtsweg
einschlagen möchte was bedeutet das
ganze für die spd so eine
schlammschlacht herz naja für die spd
bedeutet ist dass man sich ruhe erhofft
das war ja immer das problem dass
sarrazin thesen vertreten hat die viele
in der spd spitze zumindest nicht
vertreten und das ist da seit ewigen
zeiten geknirscht hat und dass es immer
den versuch gab ihnen rauszuwerfen und
das ist jetzt zumindest vorerst vorbei
man muss sagen inhaltlich haben sich
partei und der autor der frühere
berliner finanzsenator tatsächlich
politisch auseinander gelebt da gibt es
nichts dran zu beschönigen
nur die ob die erhoffte ruhe eintreten
wird das wird man halt sehen weil der
restliche rechtliche weg natürlich noch
sehr sehr lang ist